clap if you know the michelin man yeah
clap of hands who knows about this new
phenomenon of voice texting
hands who wants voicemail to just go
away clap of hands who would be slightly
missed if you sneezed and your partner
didn't say bless you raise your hand do
it raise your hand if you have raise
them up raise of hands how many people
think this woman even if she couldn't
get herself off the chain just stop
looking raise your hand if you're into
second chances you show up hands how
many people think it makes you feel a
little cagey and weird when someone says
they gotta go right when they start the
event show of hands who thinks this is a
prudent way to live you can get more
done show of hands who likes spoilers
who likes this concept show of hands who
here would never sleep in the news who
is gonna go to the movie theater who's
slinging lava around the deep fried
turkeys has anyone here had kids how
many people in the audience have been
glamboozled has anyone here ever like
deep fried a turkey